[Music]
J is on the phone in Philadelphia hi J
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
appreciate your taking my call I just
had to ition expenses coming up in the
next two years I'm actually starting
business schools and I just wanted some
advice how to run around with my
finances the first thing I don't want to
do is take a student loan because I've
started following users last month and
so I just want to make sure I get to
college without getting a student loan
and Halle and how my finances will work
across it each other the way you ask a
question it sounds like you're already
enrolled yes I am actually starting this
fall okay and what's your school Temple
University in Philadelphia okay and what
does that cost so the way I'm looking at
the tuition rates it's going to be some
around 70 or 75 thousand dollars how
does it cost per year tuition tuition it
would be twenty five four years and
there's a couple of overheads there's an
international program as well that pays
for under ten thousand there that pays
for ten thousand of the twenty five
no I meant the 25 per year and plus plus
ten that's that's what I'm going to be
incurring the cost thirty five thousand
dollars a year yeah just about okay and
where are you going to get thirty five
thousand dollars a year so we have
thirty thousand dollars in savings and
we have twenty thousand on the other
investments and I actually have a twenty
five thousand car loan going on which
was kind of stupid of me I'm just 28 so
we just wanted to see how we can run
around with that debt and also the
expenses coming out well the problem
I've got is this you are emotionally and
actually committed to a university that
you possibly can't afford
and so that makes this conversation
difficult well because and not only do I
have to talk you into doing some things
to not take on student loan debt but the
number one way to avoid student loan
debt is go to a university you can
afford right that is less expensive in
other words than this one okay and I'm
not mad at that University but you can
go to school a lot cheaper than thirty
five thousand dollars a freaking year to
get a business degree like 1/4 of that
well no more like more like a third of
that but I mean ten twelve thousand
dollars a year's in-state tuition for
most universities right so actually my
wife is currently working and she has
she has a take home of around sixty
thousand so we were we were thinking we
can work around with something of her
income as well which will come into play
okay here's what you're gonna have to
figure out and you have to decide this I
can't decide this but from my seat I
would have to tell you to ask yourself
the question if we have a sixty thousand
dollar income and we have a couple of
pieces of savings and we have a stupid
car debt that's a problem that we need
to get rid of and we want to go to
school and get a degree in business why
are we paying thirty five thousand
dollars a year when we could do it for
twelve right because you don't have the
money I mean if you told me that we said
hey you know Dave Mike my grandpa left
me a half million dollars I'm going to
temple and I'm gonna pay for it cool I
got no issue with that no problem at all
if that's what you want to do but you've
chosen a car you can't afford and now
you've chosen an education you can't
afford right very difficult to
mathematically avoid debt when you've
got more going out than you have coming
in so it's very hard for me to have you
know for me to have a successful
conversation with you because it's not
just about the math here I actually have
to talk you out of something you've got
your heart set on and it's not to say
don't get
education let me just tell you there's
about five things you can do to avoid
student loan debt the number one thing
by far that avoid student loan debt
listen parents number one thing that
keeps kids out of student loan debt
biggest thing of all cost of school
where you go school and school will
range between twelve thousand dollars a
year tuition maybe eleven thousand
depending on what state you're in up to
about a hundred thousand a year tuition
and so you can go two hundred fifty
thousand dollars in debt like the lady I
talked to yesterday to get him you know
an undergraduate degree in psychology
it's what she had done two hundred fifty
thousand dollars to get a psych degree
[Music]
the reason we have a student loan crisis
is not the cost of education its choice
of education and choosing not to work
while you're in school which you're
going to be doing your wife's gonna be
doing says a lot who we're talking about
with you sir
but you know you're gonna have you're
gonna be in debt with the choices you've
laid out in front of me unless her
income goes up your income goes up or
there's another variable you didn't give
me that has money attached to it and
you're selling this stupid car this is
the Dave Ramsey shop